Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast über Raumfahrt und andere.
Kosmische Angelegenheiten.
Das ist Ausgabe Nummer 120 und heute mal wieder was ganz Besonderes,
denn jetzt bin ich mal nicht irgendwo hingefahren, sondern in Berlin geblieben
und bin nur um die Ecke mal schnell in das Zeiss Großplanetarium hier in Berlin-Prenzlauer Berg.
Und das bedeutet auch, heute haben wir Zuschauer und die begrüße ich als allererstes
mal ganz kräftig. Hallo!
Ja, sehen tun wir sie nicht, weil hier ist es ganz dunkel.
Wenn man irgendwie die Sterne auch noch mit betrachten möchte,
wir nutzen natürlich heute auch die Kuppel, aber wir bleiben natürlich im Inhalt, hier ganz im Audio.
Und ja, worum geht es denn heute? Heute habe ich einen besonderen Gast und den
begrüße ich dann auch gleich mal, nämlich Ulf Merbold. Herzlich Willkommen bei Raumzeit.
Ja, vielen Dank.
Ich, Merbold, oder sollte ich besser sagen 10972 Merbold. Sie wissen, was das ist, ne?
Nein, ich weiß nicht, müsste mir mal auf die Sprünge helfen.
10972, das ist ja die Nummer des Asteroiden, der nach Ihnen benannt ist.
Ja, schon alles so lange her, habe ich schon vergessen.
Das kann ich mir vorstellen. Ich dachte, ich erwähne es nochmal.
Nochmal, aber da muss man ja was geleistet haben.
Haben sie ja auch, sie sind Astronaut im Ruhestand, kann man sagen.
Und waren oft im All.
Gerade als ich hier ankam, habe ich so ein Filmplakat noch gesehen.
Hier gibt es ja auch ein Kino.
Der Mann, der nie im All war, heißt der Film. Das ist ja im Prinzip genau das Gegenteil.
Dreimal haben sie die Erde verlassen, also zumindest mindestens 100 Kilometer
Abstand genommen. Das gelingt ja auch nicht jedem.
Also ist man dann einfach so ein bisschen Astronaut auf Lebenszeit?
Also ist das so eine Art Titel? Ist das so wie Bundeskanzler,
was man da nicht mehr los wird?
Das ist eine schwierige Frage. Ich meine, von Beruf bin ich Physiker.
Bevor ich in die Raumfahrt kam, habe ich zehn Jahre richtig solide,
experimentell Festkörperphysik an einem Max-Planck-Institut betrieben.
Und dann kam die Raumfahrt in mein Leben. und auf die Weise wurde ich eben in
der ESA und bei der NASA als Astronaut geführt und bei den Russen als Kosmonaut.
Das hängt mir jetzt an, aber da kann ich auch nichts dafür.
Aber das definiert einen schon, obwohl Sie empfinden das sozusagen als Aspekt,
aber für andere ist es, glaube ich, schon so die Primärwahrnehmung, oder?
Ach, ich würde mal sagen, das ist an vielen Stellen so. Einer,
der mal irgendwo Direktor war, der wird halt Direktor genannt.
Also ich habe dazu keinen Kommentar, das ist für mich ja so alles andere als wichtig.
Okay, das habe ich mir schon fast gedacht. Trotzdem ist das ja ein sehr exklusiver
Klub, in dem man sich da aufhält. Es sind ja jetzt nicht so viele Astronauten gewesen.
Ich hatte ja schon die Gelegenheit, bei Raumzeit mit ein paar zu sprechen,
mit aktuellen wie Matthias Maurer, Samantha Cristoforetti, die Sie sicherlich
auch alle irgendwann mal getroffen haben,
und einen alten Kollegen, Reinhold Ewald, und natürlich auch Sigmund Jähn.
Und mit Sigmund Jähn verbindet sich, glaube ich, so einiges.
Sie kommen, glaube ich, 40 Kilometer Luftlinie mehr oder weniger aus demselben Gebiet.
Richtig, Sigmund und ich, wir sind Vogtländer, beide.
Der Sigmund aus dem sächsischen Teil und ich aus dem thüringischen Teil.
Aber am Ende, außer dass wir im Vogtland aufgewachsen sind, sind wir völlig
getrennte Wege gegangen.
Ich wollte in meinem Leben unbedingt in Jena Physik studieren und durfte nicht.
Deswegen bin ich am Ende in die Bundesrepublik Deutschland verschlagen worden,
also in die alte Bundesrepublik.
Und Sigmund wurde ein strammer Verteidiger des Sozialismus, wurde Jagdflieger und Fliegerkosmonaut.
Und insofern, unsere Wege, die sind im Grunde 180 Grad in entgegengesetzte Richtung gelaufen.
Aber durch die Raumfahrt sind wir dann doch wieder zusammengekommen.
Sie sind ja auch in etwa ähnlicher Jahrgang, ich glaube nur vier Jahre auseinander.
Ja, so ungefähr.
Und stimmt das, dass Sie sich aber gemeinsam den Mauerfall aus der Ferne angeschaut haben?
Ja, das ist richtig. Also die Jähn-Geschichte, die begann damit,
wir waren beide schon geflogen.
Ich war gerade zurückgekommen aufs Amerika und dann wurden wir nicht vom anderen eingeladen, um den 90.
Geburtstag von Hermann Obert in Salzburg mit zu feiern.
Da standen wir uns dann zum ersten Mal gegenüber und ich mache die lange Geschichte
kurz. Natürlich haben wir uns da erstmal etwas beschnuppert,
haben aber relativ schnell ein gemeinsames Thema gefunden.
Nämlich wir hatten beide die Erfahrung machen dürfen, dass 90 Minuten ausreichen,
den Erdball zu umrunden.
Und dann war das ja eine Zeit, da
war Reagan Präsident im Weißen Haus und Generalsekretär der KPTSU war...
Oha.
Ich hoffe, Sie wissen es. Ich weiß es nämlich jetzt gerade nicht.
Ich weiß es, fällt mir gleich noch ein. Jedenfalls, es war die Zeit des Kalten
Krieges und uns beiden war dann klar.
Dass es am Ende keine Gewinner geben würde, sollte der Kalte Krieg zum Heißen Krieg eskalieren.
Das war dann ein Thema, da waren wir dann relativ schnell auf der gleichen Welle
und meinten, was wir tun können,
unseren Beitrag zu leisten, eine solche Katastrophe zu verhindern,
das müssen wir dann auch machen.
Und ich bin dem Sigmund dann im Ablauf der Folgejahre, das war alles noch vor
der Wiedervereinigung, auf den IAF-Kongressen immer wieder begegnet.
Und dann wurde die DDR langsam instabil.
Und da können wir vielleicht nachher den Herrn Drexler noch dazu hören,
Der war nämlich mitbeteiligt, den Siegmund vor dem Mauerfall in die damalige
Bundesrepublik oder genauer gesagt zum heutigen DLR einzuladen.
Und dann kam er auch. Und das war dann, denke ich mal, essentiell wichtig,
um dem Siegmund am Ende zu helfen, auf der westlichen Seite der bis dato geteilten
Welt wieder in die Spur zu kommen.
Und der hat dann Beraterverträge bei der ESA und beim DLR bekommen und dann
ging es ihm eigentlich am Ende richtig gut.
Tauchen wir dann nochmal kurz in Ihre Zeit, Ihre Jugendzeit in der DDR ein.
Sie kommen ja aus Greiz und haben es ja schon erwähnt, Sie wollten Physik studieren
letzten Endes. Das war sozusagen schon auch immer bei Ihnen so drin, Welt verstehen.
Ja, das wollte ich unbedingt. Das hat mich in der Schule am meisten fasziniert
von allen Angeboten, eben was zu lernen, was herauszufinden.
Das war natürlich in der DDR auch ein Fach, in der Physik ist entweder richtig oder falsch.
Das wird durch das Experiment am Ende bewiesen und nachgewiesen und dann kann
man auch mit niemandem mehr darüber diskutieren.
Während andere Themen, was weiß ich, dialektischer Materialismus,
da ist ja nun auch jede Menge, das kann man beugen und so und so darstellen und präsentieren,
aber nicht nur aus dem Grund wollte ich Physik studieren, sondern weil es mich
auch vom Fach her über alles interessierte. Und.
Um das dann auch zu erzählen, meine Bewerbung an der Universität Jena,
die wurde abgelehnt. Ich bekam ein Schreiben vom Prorektor für Studienangelegenheiten.
Da war sinngemäß die Absage und dazu begründet,
dass ein Studium an einer sozialistischen Universität eine Auszeichnung ist,
der man sich durch herausragende fachliche und gesellschaftliche Arbeit würdig erweisen sollte.
Und mir wurde dann signalisiert, in einem Jahr könnte man vielleicht nochmal
drüber reden, wenn du eben diesen Nachweis in einem VEB-Betrieb bringst.
Das hieß ja im Klartext, wenn du jetzt in die FDJ, in die Gesellschaft für deutsch-sowjetische
Freundschaft, in die Partei eintrittst, dann könnte es schon noch möglich sein.
Ich wollte mich aber nicht kompromittieren. Die Russen hatten nämlich meinen
Vater nach dem Krieg nach Buchenwald mitgenommen.
Dort ist er verhungert und das kam für mich dann nicht in Frage.
So stand ich 19-jährig vor der schwierigsten Entscheidung meines Lebens,
entweder eben klein beizugeben oder das Physikstudium zu vergessen.
Nun gab es aber damals die Option, die DDR zu verlassen, denn in Berlin stand
1960 die Mauer gerade noch nicht.
Und dann habe ich eben diese Option gewählt, obwohl mit 19 Jahren alles hinter
sich zurückzulassen, Eltern,
Freunde, alles was einem vertraut und wichtig ist, das ist eine nicht so leicht
zu treffende Entscheidung.
Das kann ich mir ganz gut vorstellen. Das heißt, am Ende war aber so der Wunsch,
also war es die Physik, die gerufen hat oder war es überhaupt so ein bisschen
der Wunsch, mehr Selbstbestimmung ins Leben zu bekommen?
Ja, das lässt sich, glaube ich, gar nicht so trennen. Natürlich,
ich wollte nicht, wie soll ich sagen, unter diesem Druck des politischen Systems
mich in irgendeiner Weise verbiegen müssen,
aber Physik wollte ich um alles in der Welt eben ausstudieren.
Und so kam es eben dazu, dass ich diesen schwierigen Entschluss auch umgesetzt habe.
Dann ging es zum Max-Planck-Institut, denke ich mal.
Nicht zu schnell, erst mal kam das Studium. Also ich habe dann an der Universität
studiert. Ich wollte ursprünglich in Berlin studieren, West-Berlin.
Weil ich dachte, solange die U- und S-Bahnen hin und her fahren,
können mich Freunde, Verwandte auf dem Weg zur Ostsee oder wie auch immer gelegentlich mal besuchen.
Ich hatte dann, da bin ich den Kultusministern heute noch kram, ein 13.
Schuljahr machen müssen, denn nach Meinung der bundesdeutschen Kultusminister
konnte einer in der Bundesrepublik Deutschland mit einem DDR-Abitur,
das man ja nach zwölf Jahren ablegt, unter gar keinen Umständen die Hochschulreife haben.
Unmöglich ist das.
Unmöglich. Also habe ich, anstatt
dass wir da nochmal eine Prüfung machen durften, Mussten wir das 13.
Schuljahr wiederholen und es gab in West-Berlin damals im Tiergarten eine Schule,
Falk-Schule, da waren spezielle Klassen nur für DDR-Abiturienten.
Und dann haben wir die Prüfung nochmal gemacht und kaum hatte ich die Prüfung
und hatte mich schon an der Technischen Universität in West-Berlin beworben. Dann wurde am 13.
August 1961 die Mauer gebaut und dann brachte mich das doch dazu,
das Ganze auf den Prüfstand zu stellen,
um mich nochmal zu fragen, ist dann Berlin eigentlich für mich noch sinnvoll?
Das war ja dann schon eine Art Insel und ich hätte ja auch nicht irgendwie mit
dem Zug oder mit dem Auto über die Autobahn durch DDR-Gebiet fahren können,
wäre ich ja sofort in der Gittern gelandet.
Und dadurch kam es dazu, dass ich dann meine Pläne revidiert hatte.
In Stuttgart hatte ich eine Tante und so kam es, dass ich in Stuttgart studierte
und nach dem Studium kamen die zehn Jahre an einem Stuttgarter Max-Planck-Institut.
Und das kann ich vielleicht auch schon sagen, ich habe dann als Wissenschaftsastronaut
in Europa und in Amerika jede Menge Forschungsinstitutionen,
Einrichtungen von innen erleben dürfen Und im Rückblick kann ich sagen,
so ein Max-Planck-Institut für einen ambitionierten Wissenschaftler,
das ist im Grunde auch ein Paradies.
Man hat keine Lehrverpflichtung.
Das ist mir erst im Nachgang klar geworden, welches Privileg es ist,
an so einem Max-Planck-Institut zu forschen.
Zum Beispiel an Strahlenschädigungen von Stickstoff dotierten Eisen nach Neutronenbestrahlung
bei 140 Grad Celsius mit Hilfe von Restwiderstandsmessung.
Das ist meine Dissertation.
Da trott man von. Und,
Raumfahrt hat aber eigentlich bis zu diesem Zeitpunkt so eigentlich noch gar
keine Rolle gespielt, oder? Ich meine, wie war denn so Ihr Verhältnis zu dem Thema?
Es ist ja jetzt 70er Jahre, war ja auch noch eine Zeit, wo das immer noch so
die Zukunft in gewisser Hinsicht war, oder? War es schon wieder durch?
Ja gut, also vorausgegangen war natürlich der Wettbewerb zwischen der Sowjetunion
und den Vereinigten Staaten.
Und ich bin ja nicht naiv, mir war natürlich auch klar, dass die Raumfahrt im
Grunde ein Schaufenster auch ist,
um der Restwelt eben die Potenz, wissenschaftliche oder finanzielle Potenz,
natürlich auch die militärische vor Augen zu führen und das habe ich natürlich
mit Interesse verfolgt,
dass die Russen dann 1957 den Sputnik in die Umlaufbahn brachten und 61 Juri Gagarin,
die er da einmal umrundete.
Aber für mich zu diesem Zeitpunkt war klar, das ist eine Spielwiese für die
Supermächte und einer aus Europa.
Da braucht er gar nicht dran zu denken, dass er da in irgendeiner Weise mal
den Fuß in die Tür kriegen könnte.
Also ich habe das als Beobachter der Zeitläufe mitgekriegt, aber keinen Gedanken
daran verschwendet, dass ich da selber mal involviert werden würde.
Unerhofft kommt oft. Ja, weil dann hat sich ja Europa auch neu aufgestellt in
den 70er Jahren und hat sich ja auch berappelt und dann ging es ja los mit der
ersten Raketenentwicklung.
Es lief ja erstmal am Anfang nicht so gut, aber gegen Ende der 70er Jahre mit Gründung dann der ESA,
später das Ariane-Programm, die Sachen kamen in Bewegung und man wollte vor
allem dann auch einen eigenen Astronautenstamm aufbauen.
Das war ja im Prinzip so der Plan.
Ja, ich denke, also für mich war das entscheidende Thema,
dass die Europäer, damals hatte die ESA elf Mitgliedsländer und die Bundesrepublik war Mitglied,
die haben eine Einladung der NASA bekommen und auch angenommen,
einen Beitrag zum sogenannten STS zu liefern. von Space Transportation System.
Das ist im Wesentlichen der Shuttle. Und.
Das war damals insbesondere die Bundesregierung, so ein paar Ministerialeute,
Wolfgang Finke zum Beispiel,
die meinten, wenn die Einladung kommt, dann sollten wir nicht versäumen, sie anzunehmen.
Und so hat die ESA etwas getrieben durch das Mitgliedsland Deutschland auf diese Einladung reagiert.
Und das Ergebnis war, wir leisten einen Beitrag mit dem Spacelab.
Das wurde dann in Europa konzipiert, von europäischen Steuerzahlern bezahlt
und im Wesentlichen in Bremen bei der damaligen Firma Erno gebaut.
Und ich wurde eben derjenige, der am ersten Flug des SpaceLips,
der war natürlich primär im Testflug, beteiligt wurde.
So wurde ich auch der Erste, den die Amerikaner jemals mitgenommen haben.
Also erste Nicht-Amerikaner.
Aber hinzu kam natürlich, dass
die ESA dann auch dieses Desaster mit der Europa-Rakete auflösen konnte.
Da waren dann die Franzosen die Treiber. Es wurde die Ariane entwickelt,
die dann über Jahre fehlerlos im Grunde funktionierte.
Und so hat Europa dann eben auch Profil gewonnen oder man müsste genauer sagen
die ESA als Europäische Weltraumagentur wurde also peu à peu zu einem respektablen Partner.
Und vielleicht kann ich gleich mal vorweggreifen, jetzt liefern wir ja für das
Orion genannte Raumschiff den Geräteteil,
mit dem wir dann irgendwann zum Mond fliegen wollen und vielleicht später sogar noch weiter.
Weiter, damit ist die ESA oder ist Europa zum ersten Mal zu einem unverzichtbaren Partner geworden.
Denn ohne diesen Geräteteil ist dieses Orion genannte Raumschiff zu nichts zu gebrauchen.
In früheren Jahren mit dem Space Lab oder jetzt auch mit der Internationalen
Raumstation, mit diesem Columbus-Modul sind wir beteiligt, aber die Raumstation,
die könnte man auch nutzen ohne Columbus-Modul.
Und das ist ein qualitativer Schritt.
Jetzt sind wir sozusagen mit der NASA auf Augenhöhe angelangt.
Aber jetzt muss ich ja trotzdem nochmal fragen, wie Sie jetzt ausgerechnet auf Sie gekommen sind.
Weil ich meine, Astronauten, da werden sich ja einige beworben haben.
Ich glaube, in der ersten Suche waren mal so locker 2000 Leute in der engeren
oder überhaupt erstmal in der Auswahl.
Wie kam denn das Thema bei Ihnen überhaupt auf den Tisch? Also was ist denn passiert?
Ja, in meinem Fall, das war im Grunde...
Sie werden es vielleicht gar nicht glauben, ich hatte also zehn Jahre an diesem
Max-Planck-Institut mit tiefen Temperaturen Widerstandsmessungen gemacht,
um die Wirkungen von Neutronen auf kubisch raumzentrierte Metalle zu untersuchen.
Das ist durchaus auch praxisrelevant, denn diese Materialien werden in Reaktoren
natürlich gebraucht und eingesetzt.
Und da muss man ja verstehen, was unter der Wirkung dieser energiereichen Teilchen
mit dem Material passiert.
Aber nach zehn Jahren dachte ich, ich habe jetzt Superleitungen kennengelernt,
Magnetismus, mechanische Eigenschaften und so weiter.
Es wäre für mich vielleicht ein Zugewinn an Lebensqualität. Ich bin ein neugieriger Mensch.
Zu dem, was ich jetzt schon sehr gut kannte, noch etwas ganz Neues anzufassen.
So bin ich einmal in Stuttgart am Wochenende zum Hauptbahnhof, um die FAZ zu kaufen.
Denn damals war es üblich, dass irgendwelche Stellenangebote für akademisch
ausgebildetes Personal in der FAZ erschienen.
Und da fand ich eine Anzeige, da hat die damalige DLR, heutige DLR,
im Auftrag der Europäischen Weltraumagentur ESA angeboten,
experimentell erfahrene Wissenschaftler dürfen sich bewerben mit dem Ziel,
auf der ersten Spacelift-Mission die Experimente durchzuführen.
Und dann habe ich das meiner Frau gezeigt, das wäre doch eigentlich interessant,
da war eben auch eine Liste, welche Wissenschaftsdisziplinen eine Rolle spielen würden, Physiologie,
Biologie, Astronomie, Erdbeobachtung, natürlich mein Acker, nämlich die Festkörperphysik.
Dann habe ich gedacht, das wäre jetzt mal ein interessantes Programm.
Es hat mich immer so ein bisschen irritiert, dass jeder junge Mensch,
der heutzutage in der Wissenschaft was reißen will, im Grunde genötigt ist,
sich auf einen schmalen Spezialbereich zu fokussieren.
Und in der Wissenschaft, da passiert an vielen Stellen eben viel.
Und so sagt meine Frau, da kannst du dich ruhig bewerben, Da sind so viele,
die werden ganz gewiss nicht gerade auf dich warten.
Und dann nahm diese ganze Geschichte eine gewisse Eigendynamik an.
Erst hat die Bundesrepublik Deutschland unter den nationalen Bewerbern eine Vorauswahl getroffen.
Denn jedes dieser elf Mitgliedsländer der ESA durfte der ESA am Ende fünf vorausgewählte
Bewerber nominieren. und in der nationalen Vorauswahl waren zum Beispiel auch
Fura und Messerschmidt.
Die wurden an der ESA nominiert, die sind aber in der ESA-Auswahl untergegangen
und das Ganze lief ab nach dem K.O.-Prinzip.
Die billigen Tests, also zum Beispiel Sprachtests, der kostet nicht viel Geld,
die waren am Anfang und nur diejenigen, die noch gut Englisch konnten,
die wurden in den nächsten Test eingeladen, die durchgefallen waren,
waren weg Und so kamen dann medizinische Teste und nebenbei die psychologischen
Tests, die eine ganze Woche dauerten.
Die haben eigentlich die meisten Opfer gekostet. Da sind die meisten gescheitert.
Am Ende waren wir dann noch 20 bei der ESA. Esa, zu diesem Moment hat meine
Frau dann zum ersten Mal gesagt, oh Gott, am Ende bleiben die bei dir hängen.
Und so kam es dann.
Und am Ende hat die Esa gesagt.
Drei von uns unter Vertrag genommen, den Schweizer Claude Nicollier,
den Holländer Wubo Ockels und mich.
Und wir begannen dann gemeinsam das Training für diesen ersten Spacelift-Flug,
wobei unsere Aufgabe von Anfang an darin lag,
die schon ausgewählten Experimente durchzuführen und dafür zu sorgen,
dass aus jedem Experiment eben ausreichende Daten rauskamen.
Die durften dann nach vier Jahren Training, hatten sie uns vier Jahre kennengelernt,
darüber abstimmen, wem sie ihre Experimente anvertrauen wollten.
Und ich habe das Glück gehabt, dass die Mehrheit für mich optierte.
War denn das Englisch für Sie eine Hürde? Weil ich könnte mir vorstellen,
Englisch war jetzt nicht auf dem Programm in Greiz an der Schule, oder?
Nein, null. Ich habe an der Schule keine einzige Minute Englischunterricht gehabt.
Aber ich hatte ja nun in Stuttgart studiert und dann zehn Jahre an diesem Max-Planck-Institut
und am Ende dieser Jahre war ich natürlich noch lange nicht irgendwie richtig fit in Englisch,
aber es ist eben heutzutage das,
was im Mittelalter Latein war, die Sprache der Wissenschaft auf internationalen
Tagungen, ist Englisch.
Und also das war sicher nicht meine größte Stärke.
Ich nehme an, dass die mich gerade noch so durchgelassen haben,
aber dann kam ich eben zur ESA und bei der ESA habe ich 26 Jahre zugebracht
und die Lingua Franca bei der ESA ist dann Englisch. Am Ende,
glaube ich, habe ich es richtig gut gelernt.
So, und dann waren Sie Astronaut. Dies Space Lab, um die Mission ging es ja jetzt erst mal,
ist eine Raumstation, die man dann in den Space Shuttle reingepackt hat,
damit hochgefahren hat, aber man konnte ihn sozusagen entsprechend vorbereiten.
Ich frage mich immer, Space Lab, also wann ist das ungefähr gestartet,
also wann wurde das sozusagen erstmalig angedacht, dass man sowas überhaupt machen wollen würde?
Das ist unmittelbar nach Ende des Apollo-Programms kam die Einladung.
Das Apollo-Programm, das ging so 72, 73 zu Ende.
Und dann haben die Amerikaner ja entschieden, wir hören jetzt auf mit den Wegwerf-Raketen,
mit den Saturn-5-Raketen und entwickeln ein wiederverwendbares System.
Und ich kann die Frage jetzt nicht mit einer Zahl beantworten,
Aber ich denke mal, so 73, 74 wurden wir dann wie Europäer eingeladen.
Dann fiel die Entscheidung in der ESA, wir nehmen sie an, beteiligen uns.
Und die Auswahl für uns Wissenschaftsastronauten begann dann 77.
78 wurde ich ESA-Stuffmember, also ESA-Angestellter mit meinen genannten zwei Kollegen.
Und der erste Flug war dann eben 83, der Flug, an dem ich mitfliegen durfte.
Und ich will noch eines hinzufügen.
Das BSL ist nicht nur dieses Modul, dieses Fass, sondern es ist ein Baukasten
mit verschiedenen Elementen.
Dazu gehört das sogenannte Modul, also hier dieses Fass, dann hinten die Paletten,
dann dieses Teleskop an der kanadischen Aufhängung.
Dornier das sogenannte Instrument Pointing System geliefert.
Das war ein Zusatzteil zum Spacelab, das eben in der Lage war,
auch wenn der Shuttle langsam sich bewegt, das Teleskop punktgenau auf einen Stern zu orientieren.
Das sind alles Teile, die eben zu diesem Spacelab-Baukasten hinzuzählen.
Und je nach Mission, es wurden ja insgesamt über 20 Flüge mit dem Spacelab gemacht,
wurde es in den Shuttle-Laderaum mal so, mal so eingebaut.
Das Modul konnte man auch auf die Hälfte verkürzen.
Also das war schon auch ein sehr durchdachtes Zusatzelement für den Shuttle.
Es wertete den amerikanischen Shuttle, der ja eigentlich ein Transportsystem ist,
dass eben die Transportkosten reduzieren sollten, weil es wiederverwendbar war,
im Gegensatz zu den früheren Raketen, auf von einem Transporter zu einem wissenschaftlichen Labor.
Allerdings der Nachteil war, das ganze Ding, der Shuttle mit dem Spacelab im
Laderaum, konnte nur so lange in der Umlaufbahn verbleiben, wie der Shuttle Energie hatte.
Die hat er nämlich in Form von Wasserstoff und Sauerstoff von der Höhe 0,
das käblich ja praktisch auf Meereshöhe, in die Umlaufbahn mit hinaufgeschleppt.
Diese Elemente, die wurden in Fuel Cells dann fusioniert und entstand Wasser
als Abfallprodukt und Elektrizität zum Betrieb aller elektrischen Systeme,
des Lebenserhaltungssystems, der Radios,
der Lageregelung etc.
Und bevor Wasserstoff und Sauerstoff eben verbraucht waren, musste der Shuttle
am Boden stehen, sonst wären im wörtlichen Sinn dort oben die Lichter ausgegangen.
Warum ich nach der Jahreszahl gefragt
habe, war natürlich, weil ich mich gefragt habe, wer zuerst da war.
Das richtige Spacelab oder der Song von Kraftwerk mit demselben Namen?
Aber ich sehe, Kraftwerk hat sich sozusagen an der Realität orientiert.
Hätte ja auch andersrum sein können, dass Kraftwerk das so singt und dann baut die ESA das nach.
Da müssen wir vielleicht mal das ESA-Management fragen. Also für mich zählt
natürlich das materielle Spacelab und nicht alles andere.
Aber haben Sie Kraftwerk gehört auf dem Spacelab? Nein. Nein.
Wir durften ja damals nur ganz wenig Personal Items, wie es so schön hieß, mitnehmen.
Und ich habe mich dann für eine Kassette, Damals gab es die Kassetten,
wie man sie früher auch im Auto hatte, mit dem ganz schmalen Bändchen, mit klassischer Musik.
Also ich bin ein großer Verehrer von Mozart und Bach und das ist für mein Leben
auch eine Labung, wenn immer ich die Musik höre, das finde ich unwerflich.
Kann ich sehr gut verstehen. Ich denke, der Sprung von Bach zu Kraftwerk ist
gar nicht so groß, wie man vielleicht vermuten möchte.
Beide auf ihre Art absolut definierend.
Der Bach, das kann man ja fast genau sagen,
fast auf den Tag genau, heute vor 300 Jahren hat Bach an der Thomaskirche in
Leipzig seinen Dienst als Kantor angetreten und das muss man sich auch nochmal vergegenwärtigen.
Der ist 65 Jahre alt geworden und was der der Menschheit hinterlassen und geschenkt
hat, das ist ohne Beispiel. spielen.
Absolut. Tokata und Fuge forever.
Okay, kein Kraftwerk im Weltraum. Das nehme ich jetzt mal so hin.
Also Sie hätten mir jetzt auch einfach das Gegenteil behaupten können.
Das hätte ich jetzt auch einfach geglaubt.
Nein, ich lüge nur, wenn es anders gar nicht geht.
Okay, später dann vielleicht. Gut.
Das war also dieses Space Lab, eine Vision, die eigentlich super geklappt hat.
22 Mal kam es, glaube ich, zum Einsatz, das ist ja schon mal eine ganze Menge.
Da hat das ja mit dieser Wiederverwendbarkeit eigentlich auch funktioniert,
während es ja beim Space Shuttle dann auch irgendwann ein Kostenproblem war.
Aber dieser erste Flug, 83, als erster Nicht-Amerikaner an Bord,
ich glaube, die Crew waren sechs Leute.
Genau, ja.
Nehmen Sie uns doch mal kurz noch mal mit so auf diese Reise.
Ich meine, man geht so zum Bahnhof, schlägt die Fatz auf, denkt sich so,
Astronaut, das wäre doch mal was für mich.
So, dann wird man das und dann steht man dann irgendwann an diesem Raketenstartplatz,
und wartet da drauf, dass irgendwie eine riesige Explosion unter einem stattfindet.
Was geht einem da durch den Kopf? Also geht einem da überhaupt noch was durch den Kopf?
Naja, ich denke mal, das muss man vielleicht noch ein bisschen ausholen.
Wir hatten ja fünf Jahre trainiert.
Also ich habe mich mit diesen Experimenten wirklich bis ins feinste Detail auseinandergesetzt,
erst mal zu verstehen, was wollen die eigentlich Neues herausfinden.
Aber dann, es genügt ja nicht zu wissen, was die machen wollen,
was rauskommen soll, sondern man muss dann mit dem Instrumentarium,
das einem mitgegeben wird, auch umgehen können.
Und insofern haben wir natürlich die Instrumente, die Geräte gelernt und bedient
und die Software, die dahinter lief.
Und dann fiel eben die Entscheidung, ein Jahr vor dem geplanten Start,
dass ich derjenige werden sollte, der nun diese Aufgabe übernimmt.
Das Drama des Startes, das begann für mich in dem Moment, wo die uns am Keeb
in die Quarantäne gesteckt haben.
Denn dann, wenn man also Teil der wissenschaftlichen Welt ist,
dann ist es ein unglaublich schönes und spannendes Leben, an diesen Diskussionen
immer beteiligt zu werden.
Was könnten wir noch machen und wie können wir das noch überprüfen und so weiter.
Mit einmal wurden wir praktisch gefangen gesetzt.
Und Quarantäne heißt von der Welt isoliert. Wir durften niemandem mehr sprechen.
Macht ja auch Sinn. Man möchte natürlich niemanden in die Erdumlaufbahn jubeln,
der noch eine verkappte Infektion in sich hat und dort oben dann womöglich Fieber bekommt.
Aber jetzt saßen wir da rum und haben uns unglaublich gelangweilt.
Wie lange ist der Zeitraum?
Das sind sieben, acht Tage. Und in diesem Crew Quarters am Cape da unten,
da gab es so ein Videoapparat mit einer einzelnen Kassette und es war Casablanca.
Ich habe Casablanca in meinem Leben.
Jedenfalls.
Der Beginn einer wunderbaren Freundschaft.
Ja, dann kommt dann am Tor,
irgendwann kommt die Stunde der Wahrheit, dann wird man eben geweckt und dann
gibt es noch ein großes Frühstück, dann werden die Raumanzüge angezogen,
die bei diesem ersten Flug,
meinem ersten Flug, ganz normale Nomex-Anzüge waren, ohne jede Drucksicherung oder sowas.
Wir hatten nur einen Helm mit so einer Gummidichtung ums Kinn rum.
Für den Fall, dass es Rauch geben würde, hätten wir einen gewissen Schutz gegen Rauch gehabt.
Später wurden nach Challenger Druckanzüge benutzt.
Und dann fährt man mit dem Bus.
Sie meinen die Challenger-Explosion?
Challenger-Katastrophe.
Zwei Jahre, glaube ich, nach dem Flug war das.
Dann fährt man mit dem Bus zum Startplatz, Plattform Zürich-Rhein und mit dem
Aufzug geht es dann hoch.
Da habe ich zum ersten Mal gedacht, na hoffentlich ist die Resttechnik in einer
besseren Verfassung als dieser Aufzug, der uns da hoch zur Luge brachte.
Muss also ich bedenken, da unten ist ja direkt der Ozean und das ist eine korrosive
Luft. Oft das ganze Stahlzeug, was da gebaut ist, das war an Teilen rostig.
Aber jedenfalls, dann steigt man in diese Kiste ein.
Halb liegend oder liegend auf dem Rücken festgeschnallt. Dann hilft ein Astronaut,
der dann am Ende nochmal aussteigen muss natürlich, der Besatzung,
dann wird die Luke verschlossen.
Und dann war da für uns im Mittag nur so ein kleines Fenster, so wie ein Bullauge.
Da konnte ich einen kleinen Sektor des Himmels sehen. Und dann kam da eben blauer
Himmel, wurde dann sichtbar.
Da kann man sich natürlich fragen, warum sind diejenigen, die beim Einsteigen
behilflich waren, jetzt auf sieben Kilometer Entfernung gegangen?
Die Antwort ist ja ziemlich klar. Ich will vielleicht mit Zahlen darauf reagieren.
Der Shuttle hat ein Startgewicht mit allem drum und dran über den Daumen 2000
Tonnen. und davon sind weit über 90 Prozent gut brennbares Material.
Aber mich hat noch mehr als die Sorge, dass da irgendwas schiefgehen könnte.
An mir hat genagt die Frage, werde ich am Ende dieser Mission denjenigen,
die mir jetzt die Experimente anvertraut haben,
ausreichend gute Daten, also gut im Sinne von Qualität und Quantität,
zurückbringen können, damit die Frage, die das jeweilige Experiment stellt,
eine umfängliche Antwort finden kann.
Und wir hatten immerhin 72 Experimente.
Das hat mich schon in dieser 2-Stunden-Zeit, das ist die Endphase des Countdowns, schon gequält.
Aber wenn dann Dynamik aufkommt, das beginnt ja damit, Man kann das alles mithören,
wie da die Stadtvorbereitungen vorangehen, der Countdown voranschreitet.
Wenn dann am Ende die Triebwerke hochlaufen, die der Shuttle ja mit Wasserstoff
und Sauerstoff betreibt, dann kommt Dynamik auf.
Dann dauert es sechs Sekunden, bis die den vollen Schub entwickeln und in der
Zeit bewegt sich der Shuttle so ein kleines bisschen nach vorne.
Der hängt nämlich ein bisschen schräg und wenn jetzt der Schub kommt,
dann kommt dann die richtige vertikale Orientierung. In diesen sechs Sekunden
muss ich, ich habe ein großes Problem mit Computern.
Ich bin nicht sicher, ob mir Computer Lebenszeit genommen haben oder ob sie
geholfen haben, Zeit zu sparen.
Das ist also eine für mich nicht beantwortete Frage in meinem Leben.
Aber in diesen sechs Sekunden ist es gut, dass wir welche haben,
denn jetzt muss man Hunderte von Ingenieurparametern, Drehzahlen,
Temperaturen, Öldruck etc. etc. pp.
Prüfen, ob sie, wie die Piloten sagen würden, im grünen Bereich liegen und,
Ist das so, dann werden die Solid Rocket Boosters gezündet und was dann passiert,
das kann man mit Sprache niemand schildern.
Dann hat man, also die Dinger sind wie Silvesterknaller, an oder aus,
aber man kann sie nicht abschalten.
Dann geht die Reise los, so oder so.
Und dann hat man 3000 Tonnen Schub unterm Hintern und das sieht von Ferne eigentlich
gar nicht so rasant aus, aber in Wahrheit ist das unglaublich.
Vertikal nach oben braucht die Kiste mit 2000 Tonnen Startgewicht ungefähr 50
Sekunden, bis es Schallgeschwindigkeit erreicht.
Und dann geht es eben 40 weiter. Zwei Minuten, zehn Sekunden sind die Solids
ausgebrannt, werden weggeworfen.
Dann geht die Beschleunigung nochmal runter, weil ja der Schub aus dem Solid
Rocket Bus, das plötzlich nicht mehr da ist.
Und dann, sagen die amerikanischen Kollegen,
ist der weitere Aufstieg electrostatic, weil die Flüssigkeitstriebwerke,
die sind ganz anders als die Solids, die sind nämlich hohl und brennen nicht
etwa von unten nach oben, sondern radial.
Das ist im Grunde wie so eine Bierflasche, wenn ich hier drüber blase.
Von innen nach außen.
Dann hört man eine akustische Oszillation.
Im Falle der Solid Rocket Boosters liegt die unterhalb der Hörbarkeit,
aber die ist trotzdem 6 Hertz gigantisch und schüttelt das ganze Ding durcheinander.
Und wenn die dann weg sind, dann wird es sehr viel komfortabler.
Vielleicht kann ich es auch gleich sagen, deswegen ist die russische Soyuz-Rakete,
die ja nur Flüssigtriebwerke hat, im Grunde angenehmer als so ein Shuttle.
Abgesehen davon, dass so eine Soyuz-Kapsel unheimlich eng ist.
Aber die Triebwerke, die sind nicht so vibrationsmächtig wie die Solid Rocket Boosters.
Verstehe.
Dauert es acht Minuten, 30 Sekunden, bis man die Umlaufbahn erreicht hat.
Das ist natürlich ein Ritt. Da kann ich jedem, der hier sitzt,
eigentlich nur wünschen, wenn er das wünscht, dass ihm das Glück wieder fährt,
da mal mitmachen zu dürfen.
Das ist nicht möglich, so etwas mit Sprache zu schildern. Das ist ja auch anders als im Auto.
Also ich wohne jetzt in Stuttgart und dort werden Autos gebaut,
Also nicht die schlechten, aber die beschleunigen von 0 auf 100 immer besser als von 100 auf 200.
Aber jeder Raketenstart ist genau umgedreht. In dem Maße, wie das Ding leichter
wird, wie die Tanks sich leeren, nimmt die Beschleunigung ständig zu.
Man wird mit immer mehr Druck in den Sitz gedrückt und denkt, das gibt es gar nicht.
Also das ist so eine sinnliche Erfahrung, kann ich nur sagen.
Wie lange nimmt der Druck zu? Also es ist ja immer so ein Wettlauf,
auf der einen Seite wird man immer leichter, deswegen schneller,
Atmosphäre hat weniger entgegenzusetzen.
Der Druck nimmt stetig zu, bis man, da muss ich einen technischen Einschub machen.
Heutzutage sind die modernen Raketen, die russischen, aber auch der Shuttle
zum Beispiel, so dass sie...
Die Triebwerke am Ende auch drosseln können. Also die laufen mit voller Schubkraft,
bis man mit 3G, das heißt, bis man mit dem Dreifachen seines Gewichtes in den Sitz gedrückt wird.
Und dann wird der Schub dieser Triebwerke so gedrosselt, peu à peu,
kontinuierlich, dass man bei 3G bleibt.
Und dann kommt der Moment, der im NASA-Jargon MECO genannt wird.
Das ist die Abkürzung für Main Engine Cut-Off.
Und in dem Moment wird der Schub aller Triebwerke schlagartig abgeschaltet und
dann hängt man plötzlich in der Schwerelosigkeit.
Und ich will noch eine technische Zusatzinformation liefern.
In den früheren Jahren, in den Pionierjahren, waren auch die Flüssigkeitstriebwerke an oder aus.
Das bedeutete, dass die am Ende zum Beispiel im G-Mini-Programm kurz vor Brennschluss
mit 5G-Beschleunigung drin saßen.
Dann musste man aber die ganze Struktur des Raumschiffes, aber auch der Rakete
so auslegen, dass sie 5G plus Reserve standhält.
Und in dem Moment, wo man diese regelbaren Triebwerke zur Verfügung hatte,
konnte man die Strukturen leichter machen und das, was man am Strukturgewicht
einspart, kann man dem Kunden natürlich verkaufen.
Dann kann so ein Ding durch die Regelbarkeit
mehr Masse in die Umlaufbahn mitbringen und das bedeutet Kohle.
Und insofern ist das erstens mal finanziell günstig, die Regelbarkeit und für
die Besatzungen angenehmer.
Verstehe, okay, aber 3G ist schon ein Brett, also was?
3G, da können Sie Skat spielen, das ist überhaupt kein Problem.
Haben Sie Skat gespielt?
Nein, natürlich nicht, aber ich kann Ihnen sagen,
ich war ja dann auch noch bei den Russen, habe ja das Glück gehabt,
auch noch mit den Russen zur Mir zu fliegen Und die Russen, die fliegen zu mir
oder heutzutage zur ISS mit der Soyuz-Kapsel und kehren mit der Soyuz auch zurück.
Bei der Soyuz beim Wiedereintritt oder auch wenn irgendwas beim Start in die
Hose gehen sollte, kann man einen ballistischen Wiedereintritt machen.
Dann hat man für, jetzt muss ich irgendeine Zahl sagen, für zwei Minuten 8G.
Und die Russen, die wollten von jedem von uns den Nachweis, ist,
dass wir die 8G-Belastung durchstehen, ohne dass es uns schwarz vor Augen wird.
Und das kann ich Ihnen sagen, wir mussten alle auf eine Zentrifuge und die wurde,
immer mehr hochgefahren, bis eben die 8G-Anlagen und dann zwei Minuten 8G durchstehen,
da kann ich Ihnen nur sagen, da geht die Uhr viel zu langsam.
Das ist ein, sagen wir mal, einer, der ein Tornado fliegt, der sagt,
ich habe 8G gezogen. Ja, das macht ja fünf Sekunden. Einmal zack, da rum.
Aber fünf Sekunden ist eine völlig andere Situation als zwei Minuten.
Ja. Also was macht das mit dem Körper?
Ist das dann Schmerz oder ist das Unwohlsein oder ist das Atemnot?
Also was ist das eigentliche Problem in dem Moment?
Das eigentliche Problem ist, dass das Blut durch die hohe Beschleunigung nach
außen beschleunigt wird,
so wie in der Zentrifuge, die in der Molkerei die Sahne von der Molke trennt
und dass dann das Gehirn nicht mehr ausreichend mit Sauerstoff versorgt wird
und dass es einem schwarz vor Augen wird und man wird besinnungslos.
Und inwiefern ist die körperliche Fitness oder ist es eine körperliche Eigenschaft?
Inwiefern kann der Körper das verhindern? Ich meine, wenn man da so zu Butter
geschlagen wird, was soll man denn da machen?
Verhindern kann man es eben, das können Ihnen die Jagdflieger der Luftwaffe
auch genau erzählen, indem man also alle Muskeln anspannt.
Rein, die Lunge voll und dann alle Muskeln anspannen, so ähnlich wie auf dem Klo vielleicht.
Also die Beinmuskulatur, die Bauchmuskulatur, um zu verhindern,
dass in die weichen Bauchorgane das Blut da geschleudert wird.
Reingedrückt wird. Reingedrückt wird. Sondern man muss dafür sorgen,
dass ausreichend Blut ins Gehirn gelangt und damit eben auch ausreichend Sauerstoff
an die grauen Zellen kommt.
Und da gibt es eben diese Manöver, die Luftwaffenflieger, die haben Antigerosen,
durften wir aber nicht anziehen, weil wir waren auch immer medizinische Versuchstiere.
Man wollte ja gerade auch beobachten, wie reagiert der Organismus und die werden
dann durch Luftdruck einfach aufgepumpt,
sodass von außen ein Gegendruck gegen diese Beschleunigungswirkung aufgebaut wird.
Das hilft natürlich ein bisschen, also an den Beinen, am Bauch hier gibt es
diese Anti-G-Hosen, die die Jagdflieger alle anhaben.
Es ist interessant, was Sie so beschreiben. Es erinnert mich ein bisschen an
meine Spontanreaktion, wenn ich im Flugzeug in so ein Luftloch lande und mir
dann irgendwie auf einmal schlecht fühle, dass ich dann auch eigentlich alles
anspanne. Aber vielleicht ist es nicht wirklich das Gleiche.
Aber bedeutet das Zentrifuge, dass man im Prinzip zwei Minuten lang wie ein
Blöder alle Muskeln anspannen muss, um sich dem entgegenzustellen?
Ja, man muss also, das ist sehr unästhetisch, wenn ich Ihnen das vormache.
Man muss da so Luft holen.
So kann man das überleben.
Immer wieder irgendwann. Toller Job, den Sie sich da ausgesucht haben.
Naja, gut. Stand in der Fatz. Alles hat seinen Preis.
Das stimmt.
Sie können hier bleiben, aber dann kommen Sie halt nicht in die Erde umlaufen.
Das stimmt. Das stimmt. Alles hat seine Vor- und Nachteile.
Genau, aber da haben sie es ja dann hingeschafft, super und zu sechst ist ja
ganz schön was los da auf dem Spacelab,
die Mission war dann zwölf Tage oder wie?
Zehn Tage.
Zehn Tage und man ist ja jetzt im Prinzip, man ist ja komplett durchgetaktet. Was waren das?
72 wissenschaftliche Experimente, die jetzt von allen sechs betreut werden müssen
oder war das nur Ihr Programm?
Nein, wir haben halt so auf diesem ersten Spacelift-Flug als Erste im Schichtbetrieb gearbeitet.
Wir waren zu sechst, drei waren im Dienst, die anderen drei waren im Shuttle-Mitteck,
respektive im Cockpit einer und haben sich erholt.
Und dann gab es einen Schichtwechsel und so ging die Mission also.
Die Experimente liefen rund um die Uhr, zum ersten Mal.
Was heißt das für den Schlaf? Also schläft man dann so Etappenhäschen-mäßig
oder ist das so eine simulierte Tag-Nacht-Geschichte?
Nein, also ein Umlauf 90 Minuten oder 89 Minuten, dann geht die Sonne 16-fach schneller runter.
Danach kann man sich nicht richten. Dann ist Nacht, führt 25 Minuten,
dann geht die Sonne wieder auf, dann ist wieder Tag. nach diesem Taktgeber können
sie ja nicht arbeiten. Es geht nach der Uhr.
Und die eine Schicht, das sind die Glücklichen, die arbeiten synchron zur Zeit in Houston.
Und die anderen, das war immer ich, die sind die Gekniffenen.
Die arbeiten also dann, wenn in Houston eigentlich Nacht ist.
Das heißt, wir mussten unseren Rhythmus umstellen. Wir waren ja vor dem Start an amerikanische ...
Ach so, verstehe. Ja, dran gewöhnt.
Tag-Nacht-Rhythmus gewöhnt. Und ja gut, also geschlafen haben wir in Kojen der
Shuttle, also der Orbiter.
Das ist der Teil des Shuttles, der so aussieht wie ein Flugzeug.
Und das ist der einzige Teil, der am Ende aus dem Weltraum auch zurückkommt
und landet wie ein Flugzeug.
Rechts im Mittag an der Wand waren drei Kojen. Da hat man die Beine in Flugrichtung
gehabt, die hatten auch so Schiebetürchen.
Die mittlere Koje war natürlich die beste, weil durch die Wölbung des Shuttles
die geräumigste die mittlere war. Und die drüber und drunter waren kleiner und ich hatte die untere.
Aber in Schwerelosigkeit braucht man keine Matratze, wenn man schon kein Gewicht
hat. Es genügt ein Blech.
Und ich habe mit dem John Young, der die mittlere Koje hatte,
das war unser Kommandant, im Sandwich-Prinzip auf demselben Blech geschlafen.
Also der von oben, ich von unten.
Schwerelosigkeit geht das ja. Und jeder hat einen eigenen Schlafsack.
Aber die Koje, die wurde also mit dem Schichtwechsel dann dem anderen auch übergeben.
Der hat dann seinen Schlafsack mit so Druckknöpfen.
Wozu brauchst du denn das Blech dann noch, also abgesehen von der Trennung,
aber ist das dann beheizt? Nein.
Also die Klimaanlage, die kann man einstellen.
Aber braucht man den Kontakt zu etwas, während man in Schwerelosigkeit in einem Schlafsack schläft?
Ja, das ist schon gewöhnungsbedürftig. Sie müssen sich mal alle vorstellen,
Sie stellen Ihr Bett in einen Aufzug, in einem, nehmen wir mal den Berliner
Fernsehturm ganz oben, und dann legen Sie sich da rein.
Ich warte, bis Sie eingeschlafen sind, dann kappe ich das Kabel und solange
wie das Ding nach unten rauscht, sind Sie schwerelos im Bett.
Also es ist genau dieselbe Situation im Weltraum.
Ja gut, aber so für ein paar Sekunden,
weiß ich nicht, ob man da so einen Schlaf so gut nachfühlen kann.
Also ich hatte ja mal die Gelegenheit, einen Parabelflug mitzumachen,
von daher so ein bisschen Schwerelosigkeit hatte ich dann auch schon mal,
aber ich war natürlich viel zu aufgeregt, um die Zeit zum Schlafen zu nutzen.
Deswegen habe ich mich immer gefragt, wie das so ist.
Schlief man da ganz normal?
Also ich habe die erste Nacht meines Lebens in Schwerelosigkeit.
Ich war vollgeklebt mit Elektroden. Das waren eben auch medizinische Experimente,
die genau danach gefragt haben, wie schläft man jetzt.
Da habe ich einen übergroßen Schlafanteil mit REM-Phasen gehabt, Rapid Eye Movement.
Das ist so die Transformation vom Wachzustand zum Tiefschlaf.
Und die Olga Gwans, das ist die Wissenschaftlerin aus Belgien,
die gerade dieses Experiment gemacht hat, Die hat das dann so interpretiert,
dass das Gehirn sehr aktiv auf diese veränderte Lebenssituation reagiert und sich darauf einstellt.
Und das äußert sich daran, dass man eben viel mehr REM-Phasen hat als sonst.
Aber später dann wahrscheinlich auch, weil wir dann eben ausreichend müde alle
waren, habe ich in Schwerelosigkeit eigentlich gut geschlafen.
Ich komme gleich noch darauf zurück.
Und interessanterweise bei den späteren zwei Flügen, die ich ja dann auch noch machen durfte,
hat das Gehirn offensichtlich zack auf Weltraum umgeschaltet und da habe ich
von Anfang an kein Problem gehabt, gleich gut zu schlafen. Nur beim allerersten Mal.
Aber ich will noch hinzufügen, bei diesem ersten Shuttle-Flug,
Ich wusste ja auch nicht, ob ich jemals noch einen weiteren kriegen würde.
Habe ich meine Schlafzeit auf das Existenzminimum reduziert?
Eigentlich sollte jeder von uns acht Stunden schlafen.
In meinem Fall war das vielleicht fünf Stunden.
Und die restlichen drei Stunden bin ich im Shuttle-Cockpit gewesen,
um aus den Fenstern zu gucken.
Denn die Gelegenheit, die darf man natürlich nicht versäumen.
Ja, kann ich mir vorstellen. Das ist natürlich jetzt so die klassische Frage,
die ich jetzt eigentlich stellen muss, was Ihnen da so durch den Kopf gegangen
ist, aber bevor wir das machen, würde mich ja nochmal interessieren, in was für einem,
also man stellt sich das immer so vor, Schwerelosigkeit,
die Unendlichkeit des Alls, totale Silence,
aber dem ist ja nicht so. Ich meine, man fliegt ja die ganze Zeit in so einer Maschine.
Wie ist denn so die Geräuschbelastung in der Situation, gerade auch wenn man
versucht einzuschlafen, also nicht gerade mit irgendwelchem technischen Gerät
hantiert und wie riecht es da?
Erstmal die Lärmsituation. Also das ist eigentlich, ja ich meine,
das ist nicht wirklich ruhig, aber es ist auch nicht wirklich nervig laut.
Insbesondere im Space Lab, da haben die Europäer ein Lebenserhaltungssystem
zustande gebracht, das diese Arbeit in diesem Modul richtig komfortabel werden ließ.
Das war sehr angenehm, hat Dornier grandios gebaut, wie so eine Chefsetage.
Es war da nicht irgendwie laut im Shuttle-Mitteck, schon ein bisschen lauter,
aber immer noch erträglich.
Dagegen die russische Raumstation, die war deutlich lauter.
Also ich war ja nun auch 32 Tage mit den Russen auf der Mir.
Da ist nicht derselbe Komfort. vor. Auf jeden Fall die Frage, stinkt es da oben?
Habe ich nicht gesagt, ich habe nur gefragt, wie es riecht.
Na gut, wie riecht es? Ich kann eigentlich nicht sagen, dass es richtig unangenehm gewesen wäre.
Die Russen, also da, wenn ich den Russen ein Kompliment mache,
die haben eine relativ rustikale Verpflegung uns mitgegeben.
Die hatten so Dosen, da war dann meinetwegen auf dem Etikett Rindfleisch mit Kraut oder mit Gemüse,
die hat man in so einem Schlitz gewärmt und dann mit dem Dosenöffner aufgeschnitten.
Und wenn da jetzt Kraut drin war, haben wir die Dose aufgemacht,
dann roch es natürlich auch noch Kraut.
Aber das Lebenserhaltungssystem, das hat das eigentlich mit Kohlefiltern,
mit Aktivkohlefiltern relativ schnell wieder absorbiert.
Ich könnte nicht sagen, dass das richtig unangenehm gewesen wäre.
Trotzdem ist natürlich eines auch klar, um Ihre Bemerkung aufzugreifen.
Die Welt, in der man dort oben lebt, ist eine völlige Kunstwelt.
Das ist also eine Blechkiste, die mit viel Technik die Bedingungen erschafft
und aufrechterhält, die der Mensch in seiner Physis haben muss,
damit er überleben kann.
Und es muss auch jedem klar sein, der sowas macht, dass er sich physisch davon
abhängig macht, dass die komplizierte Technik um ihn herum funktionieren muss.
Und natürlich ist das wahrscheinlich auf dem U-Boot ähnlich. Auf jeden Fall...
Kann ich nur sagen, unterm Strich gesehen, auf die Dauer, ist die Lebensqualität
hier in Nieden um Klassen besser als in so einer Kiste dort oben im Weltraum.
Sie können ja nicht einmal ein Fenster öffnen, um frische Luft herunterzulassen.
Und von blühenden Wiesen und blühenden Bäumen und spielenden Kindern,
von Blasmusik und Biergärten, da darf man gar nicht drüber nachdenken.
Da ist also alles andere möglich, aber sowas gibt es da nicht.
Und insofern kann ich auch sagen, alle die davon reden, wenn wir hier diese
Erde eines Tages vielleicht geschädigt haben,
es ist keine gute Idee daran zu denken, woanders hinzugehen.
Also hier ist die Lebensqualität durch nichts, aber auch gar nichts zu toppen.
Ja, ich glaube, das ist auch eine Illusion. Wir sind ja letzten Endes Teil davon.
Aber ich habe, also gut, es gibt keinen Biergarten im Weltall,
das lese ich jetzt mal so raus.
Aber der Ausblick ist ganz gut, oder? Also was macht denn das so mit einem,
wenn man da so im All von oben guckt und sich das so anschaut, das Geschehen?
Also das, was mich als erstes wirklich, wirklich erschlagen hat.
Das kann ich auch mit Sprachen nur bedingt jemand schildern.
Das war, als ich das erste Mal die Zeit fand, an ein Fenster zu gehen, rauszugucken.
Dann sah ich den Horizont als gekrümmte Linie.
Darüber den Himmel rabendschwarz. Das All ist eben leer, wenn man mal von den
paar Sternchen absieht. und von dort, wo nichts ist, kommt auch nichts.
Das ist das finsterste Schwarz, das man sich nur denken kann.
Und die Sonne leuchtet dann aus einem rabenschwarzen Himmel heraus.
Das ist der extremste Kontrast, den ich in meinem Leben bis jetzt zu Gesicht bekam.
Und dann kommt noch hinzu, der Horizont der Erdkugel ist gesäumt von einer königsblauen,
hinreichend schönen Schicht.
Und ich war als Student der Physik schon vor dem Vordiplom in der Lage,
auszurechnen, sollte ich vielleicht nochmal zurückgehen.
Wo es blau ist, ist Luft. Das muss man mal wissen.
Und ich war schon vor dem Vorderblumen in der Lage auszurechnen,
dass 50 Prozent der uns umgebenden, mit Sauerstoff versorgenden Luft in 5,5 Kilometer Höhe liegt.
Aber im Kopf war ich irgendwie nicht kreativ genug,
diese Zahl 5,5 Kilometer mal zu visualisieren in Bezug auf die Größe der Erde.
Und deswegen sage ich auch, es ist ein großer Unterschied, ob man jetzt zum
Beispiel bemannt zum Mars fliegt oder mit Robotern.
Erst wenn man mit eigenen Sinnen die wirkliche Realität sieht,
also Zahlen sind Zahlen, aber begreifen kann man es erst, wenn man es mit allen
Sinnen wahrgenommen hat.
Wie dünn diese irdische Atmosphäre ist.
Und dann denkt man natürlich sehr viel öfter und gründlicher darüber nach,
dass wir doch vielleicht ein bisschen sorgfältiger damit umgehen sollten,
denn die brauchen wir für die Sauerstoffversorgung.
Und nebenbei ist die irdische Atmosphäre auch der Schutz, der uns das UV-Licht,
das Röntgenlicht, die ionisierenden Elementarteilchen vom Leibe hält,
die ja vom All von den Sternen auch zu uns herkommen.
Und das ist also ein Moment, den wohl keiner in seinem Leben wieder vergisst,
zum ersten Mal da rausgucken und das zu sehen.
Also das war für mich nachwirkend.
Im extremsten Maße und natürlich dann rausgucken führt dann auch dazu,
dass eben nach spätestens 40 Minuten die Sonne untergeht und dann ist man auf
der Nachtseite der Erdumlaufbahn und hat dann diesen grandiosen Sternenhimmel über sich.
Wir haben ja hier schon drüber geredet, dass in diesem Planetarium die Sterne
zum Funkeln gebracht werden, durch eine Hochtechnologie Projektion.
Wenn sie die aber von der Raumstation, vom Shuttle, von der ISS aussehen,
dann funkeln sie nicht Weil man sich ja nicht mehr durch die irdische Luft hindurch sieht,
sondern ohne Luft dazwischen Und das ist dann, also ich muss eigentlich sagen,
das Funkeln finde ich eigentlich poetisch Aber der Sternenhimmel ist natürlich
auch grandios Aber genauso faszinierend ist dann auch,
aus der Umlaufbahn, gerade auf der Nachtseite der Umlaufbahn,
nach unten zur Erde zurückzuschauen.
Dann sieht man nämlich die Küstenlinien durch die hunderte von Fischerdörfern,
durch künstliche Lichtquellen bestens markiert.
Und die Millionenstädte, die
sind auf der Nachtseite sehr viel leichter zu finden als auf der Tagseite,
weil da eben jede Menge Beleuchtung sie darstellt und das ist also auch grandios.
Also gerade Italien zum Beispiel, das ist auf der Nachtseite bestens sichtbar.
Waren Sie der einzige Astronaut auf dem Flug, der den ersten Flug gemacht hat?
Nein, auf dieser ersten Spacelift-Mission waren zwei, die vorher im Weltraum waren.
Einer der Wissenschaftsastronauten vom Johnson Space Center,
der schon einmal geflogen war, war Owen Garriott.
Der war mit dem Skylab, das ist ein Projekt am Ende des Apollo-Programms schon
mal, als Wissenschaftsastronaut in der Umlaufbahn und der,
berühmteste und für mich auch einer der hellsten Sterne am Astronautenhimmel,
der dabei war, war der John Young.
Der war auf diesem Flug zum sechsten Mal unterwegs.
Der war Mercury geflogen, Gemini geflogen und dann.
Zweimal zum Mond. Es gibt nur unter den amerikanischen Astronauten,
die zum Mond flogen, überhaupt zwei, die zweimal zum Mond geschickt wurden.
Einer davon war der John bei Apollo 10. Das war der Flug, der der Landung vorausging.
Und dann war er Kommandant von Apollo 16.
Dann machte er mit dem Bob Crippen den ersten Shuttle-Flug.
Also als das Ding zum ersten Mal SDS-1 in die Umlaufbahn gelangte, war John Kommandant.
Und dann war er nun auch noch der Unglücksrabe, der mit dem ersten Nicht-Amerikaner,
nämlich mit mir, fliegen musste.
War das so schlimm?
Ja, das war schlimm. Wieso? Auf jeden Fall...
Für mich eine große Beruhigung, mit einem solchen übermäßig erfahrenen Kommandanten fliegen zu dürfen.
Und wir haben ja am Ende des Fluges auch einige Probleme gehabt,
ernste Probleme mit dem Shuttle.
Aber der John Young, der wusste, also es gibt für jedes Problem und Problemchen
in den Prozeduren ein Rezeptbuch, Wie man die Dinge identifiziert und darauf reagiert.
Das ist also äußerst hilfreich, aber nur so lange, wie immer nur ein Problem auftaucht.
Wenn dann mehrere gleichzeitig kommen, dann kommt es darauf an,
dass einer dabei ist, der genau weiß, das ist wichtig und das ist unwichtig.
Und da war ich sehr froh und glücklich, dass wir den John Young hatten,
weil der war auf dem Mond gelandet.
Das waren auch Dinge, vielleicht sollte ich über den mal erzählen, also anfänglich.
Wir waren schon im Training an den Experimenten Jahre beschäftigt,
bis dann die Besatzung nominiert wurde, die den Shuttle pilotieren sollte.
Das wurde der John Young mit dem Brewster Shaw. Der Brewster war auch einer,
der aus der Jagdfliegerei in die Raumfahrt gelangt war und flog jetzt zum ersten Mal.
Und nun muss ich Ihnen berichten.
Die Brüder, die in Houston saßen, die waren nicht alle so glücklich,
dass da plötzlich welche aus Europa da waren und darauf warteten, mitgenommen zu werden.
In Houston gab es nämlich einige Wissenschaftler, die waren am Ende des Apollo-Programms
rekrutiert worden und warteten nun schon zehn Jahre darauf, dass sie drankamen.
Und bei denen war da keine Euphorie, dass wir da plötzlich da standen und sagten,
wo ist euer Shuttle, wir fliegen jetzt.
Ich habe da von denen auch mehrere überholt, kam schneller zum Zuge als drei
oder vier von diesen alten Hirschen.
Auf jeden Fall der John, der damals Chef des Astronauten-Office war,
der hat mir anfänglich nicht die Hand gegeben.
Für den waren wir Aliens, die in die geheiligten Jagdgründe der amerikanischen
bemannten Raumfahrt Einlass verlangten.
Und deswegen zwei andere, nämlich den schon genannten Owen Gerget und meinen
unmittelbaren Partner Bob Parker,
die habe ich immer beneidet, die kamen mit zwei T-38 in Amerika immer zum Training
irgendwo hin. Was ist ein T-38?
Das ist ein wunderschönes Trainingsflugzeug, Jetflugzeug mit zwei hintereinander liegenden Sitzen.
Und die kamen dann meinetwegen nach Boston ans MIT, wenn wir da die nächsten
Tage dort trainieren sollten.
Und dann ging es meinetwegen weiter irgendwo anders hin und dann sind die immer
mit leeren Sitzen geflogen. Und ich habe da anfänglich gedacht,
so blöd, ich würde dazu gerne mit einsteigen, mit so einem schnittigen Jet da.
Die durften aber keine Nicht-NASA-Astronauten mitnehmen.
Und insofern habe ich mich dann irgendwann gewaltig gewundert,
dass auf meinem Trainingsplan plötzlich drauf stand T-38.
Da habe ich gedacht, da hat einer einen Fehler gemacht. Aber ich habe gedacht,
bloß keine dummen Fragen stellen.
Ich bin in Houston zur Edwards Air Force Base, habe den Trainingsplan gezeigt,
habe gesagt, hier steht bei mir auf dem Trainingsplan, jetzt brauche ich einen
Helm, eine Sauerstoffmaske, Fallschirm.
Wurde mir das ausgehändigt und dann stand ich nun da rum und dachte,
jetzt bin ich ja mal gespannt, was passiert. Dann kam da einer angewackelt,
von der Ferne habe ich gedacht, das kann nicht stimmen, der läuft wie der John Young.
Und tatsächlich war es der John Young, aber da hat der sich Zeit genommen,
mit mir da fliegen zu gehen.
Gab es da eine Sondergenehmigung dann auf einmal?
Der hat jetzt verlangt, bevor ich mit dem in den Shuttle steige,
muss ich mit dem T-38 fliegen.
Das war seine Forderung und so kam ich zu dieser Ehre, nicht nur T-38 zu fliegen,
sondern mit dem Zhonyang zu fliegen.
Und dann starteten wir in Edwards, raus übers Meer, also nach Süden,
ist ja dann der Golf von Mexiko und dann fing der John an, halt Loopings, Rollen und so weiter.
Dann bin ich der Luftwaffe im Nachgang noch sehr dankbar, dass ich eben auch
mehrfach da mitfliegen durfte, Starfighter, später dann den Alpha Jet und insofern,
der hat mich da nicht aus dem Gleichgewicht gemacht.
Ich habe dann vielleicht nach einer halben Stunde gesagt, John,
wir haben ja da auch, wie wir beide jetzt, so Kopfhörer, konnten miteinander reden.
Could I also have some stick time? Also die Hand am Steuerknüppel.
Dann hat er schon die Hände hoch, da saß er vorne, hochgehalten,
konnte ich von hinten sehen, dann habe ich gesagt, you got it.
Und dann habe ich Gehs gezogen, die Kiste, die hat nur so um den Looping rum geschüttelt und,
Man sieht das, das Flugzeug hat eine ganz kleine Spannweite.
Und die Rollachse, das fliegt eine 360-Grad-Rolle schneller als eine Sekunde.
Wenn Sie das quer runter ein bisschen einschlagen, zack, ist das rum.
Na ja, gut, und dann sind wir zur Landung zurückgeflogen, nach Edwards.
Und dann habe ich mich artig bedankt übers Internet, Intercom.
Das war großer Spaß. Und dann hat er gesagt, well, you enjoyed it. Ja, very much so.
Obwohl die Spritwarnung schon rot war, hat er schon das Gas nochmal reingeschoben,
haben wir noch eine enge Platzrunde gedreht, dann sind wir gelandet.
Und von dem Moment an hatte ich gewonnen.
Dann war ich bei ihm akzeptiert und ich bin am Ende ein richtig guter Freund von ihm geworden.
Und umgedreht auch. Wir haben uns privat viel gesehen und leider ist er verstorben.
Aber das war diese John-Young-Erfahrung und im Weltraum dann hatte ich das Glück,
mit ihm auf derselben Schicht arbeiten zu dürfen und da hat er dann Geschichten erzählt,
die in keiner NASA-Publikation drin sind, was auf dem Mond passiert ist.
Jetzt muss man sich mal vorstellen, wir sitzen mit dem am Abend,
also einen Tisch gibt es ja nicht beim Abendessen.
Der John war sich nicht zu fein für uns Wissenschaftler, die Mahlzeiten zuzubereiten.
Wenn wir dann aus dem Space Lab ins Mitte kamen, dann war das ein Weg,
etwas von der Hektik zur Ruhe zu kommen.
Dann hat der John erzählt, wie er den lunaren Geschwindigkeitsrekord mit dem
Mondauto aufgestellt hat und was da sonst noch alles passiert ist.
Das muss man sich mal vorstellen.
Man sitzt mit einem, der auf dem Mond war, in so einer Kiste und während des
Abendessens fliegt man einmal selber um die Erde rum.
Wow. Okay, also sie sind auf jeden Fall ordentlich durchgetestet worden,
ob sie auch ein richtiger Cowboy sein können.
Das ist der Johnny hier.
Meine Frage, ob da noch andere dabei waren, die das erste Mal geflogen sind,
ging ja mehr so in Richtung mit,
gibt es da, also sie haben ja dieses persönliche Erlebnis geschildert mit,
oh Gott, jetzt hier Erde und die Atmosphäre und es ist ja alles ganz unglaublich.
Das teilt man ja dann sicherlich dann auch unter den ganzen als einen anderen
Novizen in gewisser Hinsicht.
War das so eine kollektive Wahrnehmung? Also war das bei allen gleich?
Oder hat dann jeder irgendwie seine eigene Wahrnehmung?
Nein, also man ist in der Situation eigentlich sprachlos.
Man redet eigentlich erst hinterher, Wochen hinterher dann drüber.
Also man sitzt da am Fenster oder hockt davor vor und guckt da raus und da kommt
so viel Aufheiden zu, dass man eigentlich gar keine,
Energie mehr hat, darüber noch zu labern, sondern das ist,
ja, ich weiß nicht, wie man das formulieren soll. Hinterher redet man dann drüber.
Schauen wir dann nochmal kurz auf die andere Mission, weil das war jetzt die
amerikanische Seite und Und jetzt reden wir ja noch von der Zeit,
wo es mit den Russen eine enge Kooperation gab, beziehungsweise die dann auch
erst begann, wenn ich das richtig sehe.
1994 war dann ihre zweite Mission, die Euromir.
Also auch hier wieder so eine Kooperation, in dem Fall halt Europa und die russische Raumfahrt.
War das wie hat sich das so abgezeichnet und wie kam es, dass sie dann da dabei waren?
Es hat sich dann abgezeichnet, es gab ja eine Zeit der Annäherung, Friedensdividende,
das waren ja solche Begriffe, die in dieser Zeit dann sich so langsam entwickelten.
Es war ja auch eigentlich im Nachgang alles in meinen Augen gut überlegt.
Die Russen, die sind unsere Nachbarn, die sind da, ob sie uns gefallen oder nicht.
Und infolgedessen für mich war persönlich natürlich die russische Raumfahrt
deswegen auch so spannend, weil der Shuttle ja nicht auf Dauer in der Umlaufbahn verbleiben konnte.
Wir haben ja schon darüber geredet, bevor die Energie erschöpft war, musste er am Boden sein.
Die Russen aber, als ich dann nach Russland kam, die hatten die Mir schon fast
zehn Jahre permanent bemannt in der Umlaufbahn betrieben.
Das heißt, die mussten die Wartungsarbeiten während des Fliegens machen,
nicht am Boden, die Nachbesserungen, aber eben auch die ganze Versorgungslogistik.
Das ist ja unglaublich spannend.
Wenn Sie dort oben in so einer Kunstwelt Menschen haben, dann müssen Sie in der Lage sein,
die mit Wasser, mit Lebensmitteln, mit Unterwäsche, mit Ersatzteilen,
mit Treibstoff, mit Chemikalien, die der Atemluft des Kohlendioxid entziehen,
zuverlässig versorgen.
Die Amerikaner mit ihrem hochentwickelten Shuttle, der aber nicht wirklich robust
war, wären dazu nicht in der Lage gewesen.
Und diese ganze Logistik, das hatten die Russen perfekt im Griff.
Die mir ist am Ende 15 Jahre bemannt betrieben worden.
Es waren mindestens immer zwei Russen dort oben.
Und insofern war das für mich eine Herausforderung, dahin zu gehen und denen
zuzugucken, wie die das machen.
Aber es war auch schwierig. Wir mussten ja am Ende alle noch mal Russisch lernen.
Das hatten Sie doch schon in der Schule jetzt.
Ja, ich habe acht Jahre russisch gelernt, aber ich wäre nach dem Abitur in Moskau
wahrscheinlich nicht in der Lage gewesen, eine Wurst zu kaufen.
Wir kannten das ganze Vokabular der Revolution.
Das war es dann auch.
Das war politisch eine Zeit, denn Gorbatschow hatte man absolviert und Jelzin
war jetzt der große Lenker und die kommunistische Sowjetunion,
die war auf dem Weg in eine bürgerliche Wirtschaftsform.
Allerdings waren die Russen, wie man im Nachhinein jetzt wohl sagen muss, überfordert.
Es war im Grunde ein gesetzloser Zustand.
Die konnten gar nicht so schnell sich umstellen und durch Gesetze das Schlimmste verhindern.
Also ich bin kein Politiker, aber ich sage das mal mit hohem Risiko.
Meine Wahrnehmung war damals, es geht drunter und drüber. Und ich denke mal,
das hat am Ende bei Russen auch dazu geführt, da gab es natürlich welche,
in einer solchen Krisensituation gibt es immer Profiteure.
Die Oligarchen, die haben sich die Staatsunternehmen unter den Nagel gerissen,
die wurden in Nullzeit stinkerreich und andere, die waren Professoren an einer
der zahlreichen Moskauer Universitäten,
mussten aber nebenbei Taxi fahren, um die Familie zu ernähren.
Also da gab es in dieser russischen Gesellschaft sicher auch sehr viel Wut und Spannung.
Und insofern, diese Transition, die kam zu schnell, in meinen Augen.
Jedenfalls, es war eine Zeit,
da haben die Russen eben die Tür aufgemacht und die ESA hat zugeschlagen und
hat den Russen für meines Wissens 50 Millionen EQs,
Accounting Units aus späteren Euros, zwei Flüge gekauft.
Und den ersten Flug, das war die Mir 94 Mission, da wurde ich dann ausgeguckt
und den zweiten machte der Thomas Reiter.
Der dauert dann fast ein halbes Jahr.
Wie lange waren Sie da oben?
32 Tage.
32 Tage. Wow, das ist ja schon ein richtiger Urlaub.
Aber eines muss ich natürlich schon sagen, also zu sehen kriegt man viel,
aber die Küche ist natürlich nicht vom Feinsten.
Jetzt was man zu essen bekommt? Oder die Wurstdosen haben Sie doch eben noch gelobt?
Naja, das ist wie auf dem Campingplatz. Ich habe sie nur nur geschildert,
wie sie sind. Da stand drauf Rindfleisch mit Gemüse und das war es auch.
Aber ich denke mal, in Berlin oder an anderen Orten kriegt man was Frisches
auf den Teller und was aus der Konservendose kommt, das kann ja gar nicht frisch sein.
Kulinarisch war es jetzt nicht so ein Erlebnis.
Das ist kein Kriterium, wenn man sowas macht.
Das kann ich mir auch vorstellen. Aber es gab ja so technische Probleme bei der Mission.
Fing das nicht gleich schon mit dem Andocken an, dass so ein bisschen aus dem Ruder lief?
Ja, das automatische Andocksystem, also die Einzelheiten kann ich Ihnen gar nicht schildern.
Jedenfalls der Sascha Wigdarenko, der wurde dann gebeten, manuell anzudocken.
Da muss man vielleicht noch ein bisschen den Rahmen schildern, das Andocken selber.
Das wollen die Experten, die im Bodenkontrollzentrum sitzen,
natürlich in Echtzeit beobachten.
Und in Russland war es so, die hatten anders als die Amerikaner keine in der
hohen Umlaufbahn positionierten Relais-Satelliten,
sondern die Echtzeitverfolgung, die war immer nur möglich, solange die Umlaufbahn
über die riesige Sowjetunion führte.
Da gab es wie an der Perlenschnur Bodenstationen, die die Signale aus dem Weltraum
übernommen haben und wir waren jetzt kurz davor, diesen Bodenkontakt zu verlieren.
Wenn man dann auf der anderen Seite der Erdkugel unterwegs ist,
dann gibt es den Funkkontakt nicht.
Und ich weiß nicht genau, ob das der
Grund war oder... Jedenfalls Sascha Wigter-Renker dockte dann manuell an.
Das funktionierte aber auf Anhieb. Und dann...
Ich mache die lange Geschichte kurz, das dauert dann lange, bis eben alle Tests
durchgeführt wurden, damit dann die Verbindung eben auch richtig fest ist und
dicht hält und so weiter.
Dann darf man schließlich umsteigen und das ist für alle Beteiligten immer ein
Festtag, denn das bedeutet für diejenigen,
die oben sind und schon lange dort oben waren, dass die ablösende Truppe an
Bord ist und dass es jetzt vielleicht auch mal frische Früchte,
Äpfel, Bananen oder sowas gibt für zwei Tage.
Und die anderen, die sind auch froh, wenn die Luke geöffnet wird,
weil sie dann aus dieser unglaublich engen Soyuz-Kapsel in die große Raumstation umsteigen können.
Und das ist für die auch eine signifikante Besserung der Lebensumstände.
Und insofern sind sie alle froh und glücklich, wenn das passiert ist.
Der Anflug ist ja mittlerweile schneller geworden durch eine andere Anflugstechnik,
aber Sie waren ja auch relativ lange unterwegs, also vom Start bis man dann
wirklich andockt. Wie lange hat das?
Wir haben 34 Orbits gebraucht, also über zwei Tage und so lange aushalten in dieser engen Kiste.
Also man ist zwei Tage lang quasi angeschnallt in diesem Sitz?
Nein, nicht ganz. Die Soyuz-Kapsel, auch wie sie jetzt noch ist,
die besteht im Grunde aus drei Elementen, drei Teilen.
Das ist dieses glockenförmige Teil, das ist das Einzige, was am Ende zurückkehrt.
Dazu gibt es ein Geräteteil, da ist das Triebwerk drin, die Tanks und Technik,
um das Ding eben mit dem Triebwerk zu bewegen, zu steuern, auch die Elektroversorgung.
Und vor dieser glockenförmigen, dem Landeapparat heißt es, da ist eine Kugel,
der nennt sich Bidawoy-Azek,
also der Lebensbezirk.
Die beiden Kammern, die sind beim Start durch eine innere Luke voneinander getrennt und verschlossen.
Dann erreicht man die Umlaufbahnen, dann beobachten die vom Boden aus sehr genau,
ob der Innendruck in beiden Kammern steht.
Wenn das so ist, dann bedeutet das, beide Kammern sind für sich genommen dicht, verlieren keine Luft.
Dann darf man über ein Druckausgleichsventil den Druck auf beiden Seiten ausgleichen
und dann kann man die Luke nach innen öffnen.
Dann wird es noch mal enger, weil dieses Klappding da runterkommt.
Und dann kann derjenige, der den mittleren Sitz hat, der ist direkt unter dem
Loch, in dieses größere Volumen umsteigen.
Und dann erst hat er den Platz, diesen Raumanzug auszuziehen.
Wenn man dann noch mehrere Tage warten muss, bis man andockt, macht man das auch.
Da wird es einem dann schon komfortabler. Wenn der das gemacht hat,
kann der Nächste in die Mitte rücken, auch das nachholen und so weiter.
Das ist dann schon etwas besser als in diesem ganz engen, da können Sie nicht
mal die Beine strecken, so eng ist das, Landeapparat aushalten zu müssen.
Aber bevor man nun andockt, zieht man sich in diesen inneren Landerapparat zurück,
schließt auch die Luken wieder, denn beim Andocken könnte es ja vielleicht auch
in die Hose gehen, dann würde man den Druck verlieren und sofort hinüber.
Und insofern versucht man natürlich so viel Redundanz aufzubauen,
wie man hat, um ein solches Malheur eben lebendig zu überstehen.
Aber das ist die Technik und nun muss ich das vielleicht noch ein bisschen schildern.
Wenn man ein Rendezvous vorhat.
Die Raumstation fliegt um die Erde herum, drunter dreht sich der Erdball ja
durch, innerhalb von 24 Stunden einmal um die eigene Achse.
Das heißt, wenn man dort hinauf will, um anzudocken, muss man genau dann starten,
wenn der Startpunkt unter dieser Umlaufbahn drunter ist.
Deswegen ist bei solchen Rendezvous-Flügen das Zeitfenster nur fünf Minuten.
Wenn man die fünf Minuten verpasst hat, hat sich die Erde zu weit vorangedreht,
dann würde es zu viel Treibstoff kosten, in die Bahn der schon fliegenden Station zu gelangen.
Das heißt also, das ist eine Bedingung, die bei so einem Rendezvous eine Rolle spielt.
Dann startet man erstmal in dieselbe Bahnebene wie die Station, aber tiefer.
Und dann muss man ja bedenken, wenn man ein Rendezvous vorhat,
dann nützt es einem gar nichts, wenn die Station auf der Seite der Umlaufbahn
ist und man ist selber auf der anderen, weil man sich ja dann nur um sich selber dreht.
Sondern man muss dann aus einer tieferen Umlaufbahn das Triebwerk zünden,
erstmal wieder in eine höhere Bahn gucken.
Also das nennt sich dann Phase Vanya, also die Phasen anpassen.
Sie haben es ja auf Ihrem T-Shirt drauf, wenn die Erde den Mars überholt,
dann ist die Entfernung mal klein und wenn man zu lange wartet,
ist sie wieder riesig groß.
Das ist die zweite Notwendigkeit, das dann so anzustellen, dass man zeitgleich
an der Stelle in der Umlaufbahn auch ankommt. Nicht nur in derselben Ebene,
sondern auch am selben Punkt.
Und davon hat man früher eben so lange Zeit gebraucht, weil man die Bahnparameter,
wenn man so ein Manöver gemacht hat, muss man dann erstmal genau nachmessen,
wo sind wir jetzt angelangt.
Und das ging eben nur über diesen Stationen, den Bodenstationen über Russland.
Und dann hat man einmal gemessen, hat man Daten gehabt, dann hat man gewartet,
bis die Kiste wieder über den Horizont kam.
Nach anderthalb Stunden war das so, um die Messwerte nochmal zu überprüfen.
Und wenn dann alles sich bestätigt hat, dann hat man gesagt,
jetzt kommt wieder ein Manöver.
Dazu wollte man aber auch wieder in Echtzeit dabei sein und beobachten,
wie das Manöver abläuft. Das war dann der dritte Überflug über Russland.
Wenn man den verpasst hat, hatte sich die Erde weitergedreht.
Dann muss man wieder warten, bis man diese Konstellation von Neuem hatte.
Und so kam es eben dazu, dass das in früheren Zeiten so viel Zeit kostete.
Für die Besatzung eine Zumutung.
Heutzutage machen die das in der Regel in sechs Stunden.
Schauen Sie sich gerne Science-Fiction-Filme an?
Nein, eigentlich nicht. Also ich habe ein paar gesehen, die mich auch wirklich amüsiert haben.
Space Cowboys, das ist so ein richtig guter Film.
Da funktioniert ja das mit dem Transport dann immer so hin, Tür auf, zack, bumm, rein und so.
Was geht einem da durch den Kopf?
Da geht einem durch den Kopf, dass die Fiktion die Gesetze der Physik ignorieren kann.
Aber in der Realität geht das eben nicht.
Und trotzdem ist Science Fiction wahrscheinlich auch schuld daran,
dass wir das überhaupt alles so betreiben heutzutage.
Also ich denke auch, also ich habe mir da auch Gedanken gemacht und bin darauf
gekommen, dass solche Projekte wie Raumfahrt, also da gibt es die Visionäre,
Jules Verne hat ein Buch geschrieben,
Flug zum Mond oder was weiß ich, da spielt die Naturwissenschaft zunächst mal keine Rolle.
Dann muss eine zweite Phase kommen, dann muss sich jemand hinsetzen und mit
dem gespitzten Bleistift, mit den Formeln der Physik nachrechnen, ob das geht.
Und das waren dann Tsiolkowski zum Beispiel und Hermann Obert.
Dann kommt heraus, es ist machbar, die oder jene Probleme müssen gelöst werden.
Und dazu braucht man als dritte Phase einen charismatischen Menschen.
Und das war zum Beispiel Werner von Braun, der die Politiker überredet, dafür Geld zu geben.
Und der war wahrscheinlich auch ein ziemlicher Opportunist. Der hat das Geld
erstmal von der Reichswehr genommen, dann in Peenemünde, was weiß ich,
welche Geldquellen das waren, am Ende von der amerikanischen Armee.
Also da muss man vielleicht auch ein bisschen opportunistisch sein,
egal wo es herkommt, wenn man dieses Ziel hat, die Grenzen zu verschieben.
Auf jeden Fall denke ich, das sind so die klassischen Schritte.
Einer muss erstmal den Traum formulieren, den Traum vom Fliegen,
wie in der griechischen Mythologie oder schon bei anderen.
Und dann muss jemand her und muss sich dazu Gedanken machen,
wie man es tatsächlich mit den bekannten Gesetzen der Natur hinkriegen könnte.
Und dann muss jemand tatsächlich, wie man so schön sagt, Butter bei den Fischen, muss es gemacht werden.
Also wer, denken Sie, hat da so in der Science-Fiction-Literatur am akkuratesten
in die Zukunft geblickt?
Jules Verne hat das toll gemacht. Er hat ja beschrieben, man startet von Florida
aus, kommt zurück vom Mond, landet im Pazifischen Ozean.
Das ist ja eigentlich am Ende so gekommen, passt. Er hat aber auch ein paar
Sachen nicht so richtig wiedergegeben.
Er hat zum Beispiel gemeint, auf der Reise zum Mond gibt es nur einen Moment,
wo die Gravitationskraft, die von der Erde ausgeht, von der des Mondes kompensiert
wird und dann ist man schwerelos.
Aber in Wahrheit ist man ja die ganze
Reise hindurch schon schwerelos im Koordinatensystem des Raumschiffes.
Weil man fliegt ja genauso schnell wie die Hülle. Und deswegen gibt es zwischen
dem, der drin ist und dem, was drumherum ist, ja keine Kraft.
Ja, wie Douglas Adams das mal so schön beschrieben hat, Fliegen ist eine Kunst
oder vielmehr ein Trick, der darin besteht, sich auf den Boden zu werfen, aber daneben.
Können Sie mir das nochmal erklären?
Ich habe das nicht verstanden. Fliegen ist sozusagen, sich auf den Boden zu werfen, aber daneben.
Also das, was eigentlich die Raumschiffe die ganze Zeit machen,
weil die fallen ja eigentlich auch die ganze Zeit auf die Erde,
aber halt daneben, weil sie so schnell sind. Deswegen drehen sie sich die ganze Zeit.
Genauso ist es. Der Flug in der Umlaufbahn ist ein freier Fall.
Ich kann es ja so erklären, wenn Sie hier einen haben, der einen Stein wirft,
dann fliegt der nach vorne durch die Anziehungskraft die von der Erde ausgeht,
geht er nach unten und trifft den Boden.
Wenn Sie einen haben, der besonders gut werfen kann, der wirft schneller,
dann ist der Punkt, wo der Boden getroffen wird, weiter weg.
Wenn Sie einen hätten, der mit 28.000 Stundenkilometer werfen könnte,
dann würde dieser Stein nach unten gehen, aber weil die Erde gekrümmt ist,
wird er nie unten ankommen.
Und das ist genau die Situation, die man in der Oblaufbahn hat.
Das ist praktisch ein freier Fall.
Wir könnten jetzt noch stundenlang hier weiterreden. Ich würde aber gerne zum
Ende noch mal so ein bisschen in die Zukunft blicken.
Sie waren ja dann in der Folge auch für das Astronautenzentrum der ESA zuständig.
Sie haben im Columbus-Modul der ISS mit dran gearbeitet oder mit das Projekt vorangetrieben.
Waren also dann nach dieser Astronautenzeit auch hier aktiv sozusagen auch nochmal
mit diesem Beruf weiterhin verbunden
und auch an der Planung der Raumfahrt beteiligt in gewisser Hinsicht.
Wenn Sie jetzt darauf schauen, wie sich das jetzt seitdem auch alles entwickelt
hat, wir haben jetzt die neuen Einflüsse mit vielen privaten Unternehmen,
die ja auch dazu beitragen, die ja schon so die Landschaft ein wenig verändern,
auch ein gewisses kommerzielles Interesse, was ja aufgestoßen wurde,
jenseits dieser wissenschaftlichen Perspektive, die über viele Jahrzehnte das alles definiert hat.
Was denken Sie, wo geht es hin oder wo würden Sie es gerne hingehend sehen?
Was sind die eigentlichen Ziele, die vielleicht die Menschheit mit der Raumfahrt
verwirklichen sollte, mal abgesehen von davon, wonach jetzt am meisten geschrien wird?
Ja, Sie haben das Wichtige ja schon gesagt. Wir sind im Moment in einer Übergangsphase.
Also selbst die ESA auf der letzten Ministerkonferenz hat dezidiert das Ziel formuliert,
die Raumfahrt eben peu à peu in private Hände zu geben.
Und das ist ja im Grunde auch naheliegend.
Die Raumfahrt oder die Nutzung des Weltraums, sollte ich vielleicht ein bisschen
genauer sagen, die ist ja heutzutage inhärenter Teil unseres täglichen Lebens.
Also die genaue Navigation,
also die wenigen wissen ja, dass wir Europäer mit Galileo ein Navigationssystem haben,
besser als das amerikanische und die Nachrichtenübertragung mit Satelliten, die Seenotrettung,
die Wetterprognosen, das Ganze setzt auf Raumfahrt, auf Satelliten.
Internetversorgung.
Internetversorgung. Und es ist ja völlig naheliegend,
dass sich der Staat aus diesen Diensten jetzt zurückzieht und das eben privaten
Unternehmen überlässt als Dienstleistung, die man dann bezahlt.
Und möglicherweise kommt dann eben auch eine gewisse Konkurrenz auf.
Vielleicht führt es dazu, dass damit auch die Kosten runtergehen.
Aber es gibt trotzdem noch jede Menge andere Teile, die, glaube ich,
vorerst jedenfalls bei staatlichen Agenturen bleiben.
Also das James-Webb-Teleskop zum Beispiel, das jetzt das Hubble-Teleskop ablöst
und viele ESA-Satelliten auch, die,
führen zu Erkenntnissen, die nicht irgendwie Zinsen abwerfen in Form von Geld,
nur zu Erkenntnissen führen.
Was natürlich auch Zinsen abwirft
in anderer Form, weil das ist ja die Grundlagenforschung letztendlich.
Natürlich, ich finde, das ist auch das eigentlich Tolle.
Ein Staat oder auch ein Individuum, der individuelle Mensch,
der nur danach streben würde, wie kann ich aus viel Geld noch mehr Geld machen,
Der würde ja die Geldvermehrung zum Selbstzweck machen.
Das Geld hat aber erst einen Wert, wenn ich es nutze, um damit etwas zu tun,
was mit Geld gar nicht bewertbar ist.
Wissenschaftliche Erkenntnisse oder meinetwegen auch die Förderung der schönen Künste.
Also insofern denke ich, ich komme nochmal auf die Max-Planck-Gesellschaften zurück.
Die wenigsten Deutschen wissen ja, dass wir 82 Max-Planck-Institute haben.
Dass wir uns leisten, einen bestimmten Prozentsatz des Steueraufkommens der
Wissenschaft zu überlassen, ohne ihnen abzuverlangen,
dass sie das in Geld in irgendeiner Weise verzinsen müssen.
Das finde ich, das ist eine kulturelle Leistung vom Feinsten.
Und insofern glaube ich, in der Raumfahrt wird es auch dazu bleiben.
Dabei bleiben das ein gewisser Teil eben da drin.
In diese Kategorie fällt und dazu gehört in meinen Augen eben auch die Vision.
Irgendwann das, was unsere Altförderer mit ihren Schiffen vollbracht haben,
mit unseren Schiffen fortzusetzen.
Und das würde in meinen Augen konkret bedeuten, irgendwann sollten wir zum Mars
gehen, um mal zu gucken, wie es da oben aussieht.
Also jetzt mit Menschen. Menschen, ja klar. Bei den Haas haben wir ja schon
einen Hubschrauber am Start.
Das stimmt, aber ich komme mal auf diesen Punkt, diese Roboter,
die produzieren Zahlen.
Aber ich kann aus der eigenen Erfahrung ja nochmal wiederholen,
wenn man dann mal sieht, wie dünn die Atmosphäre ist, dann wird einem erstmal
klar, wie das wirklich ist.
Und insofern denke ich, wenn ich zurückschaue in die Geschichte,
möchte, diejenigen, die wohin gegangen sind, wo vorher noch keiner war.
Nehmen wir mal Kolumbus.
1492 ist er in westliche Richtung über den Atlantik, das Meer der Finsternis,
Mare Terebrosum, wie es genannt wurde,
aufgebrochen, um einen verkürzten Seeweg nach Indien zu suchen.
Am Ende musste man das bis dato geltende Weltbild in die Tonne treten,
weil plötzlich ein neuer Kontinent
entdeckt worden war. Und Ähnliches kann man natürlich auch sagen.
Die Taucher, die Bergsteiger, Figuren wie Marco Polo, der aus China nach Italien
zurückkam und berichten konnte,
dass es dort ein hochentwickeltes Staatswesen gibt mit Verwaltung,
mit Gesetzen, mit Porzellan, mit Hochtechnologie für seine Zeit,
die Seide, Feuerwerk. Feuerwerk.
Also man kann schon sagen.
Die Erfahrung zeigt, dass wir oft die existierenden Vorstellungen korrigieren
mussten, wenn jemand wohin ging, wo vorher noch keiner war.
Und warum sollten wir jetzt am Beginn des 21.
Jahrhunderts, wir haben das Viertel schon vorbei, sagen, wir wissen schon alles,
wir gehen nicht mehr weiter.
Was am Ende an neuen Einsichten, an neuen Erkenntnissen, vielleicht auch an
neuen nutzbaren Technologien herauskommt.
Das kann Ihnen ja keiner sagen, aber die historische Erfahrung zeigt,
dass es in vielen Fällen eben zu neuen Erkenntnissen kam.
Und interessanterweise, das ist fast philosophisch, war es oft so,
dass der Mensch von seinem hohen Ross herabsteigen musste.
Hat man früher die Erde als Nabel von allem verstanden, stellte sich dann heraus,
nein, es ist einer von damals sechs bekannten Planeten und in Wahrheit ist die Sonne der Angelpunkt.
Und insofern denke ich, das ist eine Herausforderung an der Welt.
Notwendigerweise an mich, an die jetzt jungen Menschen, das zum Wagen und zum
Mars zu gehen und dort mal sich umzuschauen.
Eine Frage, die ziemlich offen darlegt, ist die Frage, das Wasser,
das es mit großer Sicherheit auf dem Mars mal gab, wo ist es jetzt?
Wenn es da weggekommen ist, könnte das auf der Erde vielleicht auch passieren.
Also solche Dinge, die stehen im Raum.
Aber eines kann ich dazu auch noch sagen, rein technisch sollten wir das erst
angehen, nachdem wir auf dem Mond eine Station haben und die betreiben.
Und diese Kunstwelt, die man ja haben muss, um zu überleben,
erst mal dort oben zu betreiben, um Betriebserfahrung zu sammeln.
Wenn dort oben alles in sich zusammenbricht, die Stromversorgung ausfällt oder
sowas, dann kann man sich vom Mond innerhalb von zwei Tagen nach Hause retten.
Wenn man aber auf dem Weg zum Nachbarplaneten Mars wäre, geht das nicht.
Insofern, dieses ganze Lebenserhaltungssystem, das muss absolut robust und zuverlässig laufen.
Sonst sollte man es erstmal nicht machen. Und das sind in meinen Augen die Dinge,
die jetzt sozusagen die Visionen sind am Horizont.
Und ich bin hundertprozentig sicher, es wird gemacht werden.
Ich bin aber nicht hundertprozentig sicher, ob wir Deutschen am Ende dabei sind oder nicht.
Denn mich frustriert unheimlich nach wie vor, dass wir Deutsche und ich müsste
sagen die Europäer insgesamt versäumt haben.
Dieses heute noch nicht genannte ATV,
dieses Automated Transfer Vehicle, mit dem wir fünfmal die internationalen Raumstationen
versorgt haben, mit Wasser, mit allem, was sie da oben brauchen.
Das ist ja ungefähr dreimal so leistungsfähig wie die russische ProGas,
die die Russen zur Versorgung seit Jahrzehnten einsetzen,
hat fünfmal automatisch angedockt und das bestand aus zwei Kammern.
Da hätte man einen geringen Aufwand treiben müssen, um diese eine Kammer rückkehrfähig
zu machen und dann noch ein Lebenserhaltungssystem rein, hätten wir ein europäisches
Raumschiff haben können.
Aber die Europäer, das sind in meinen Augen, ich sage es jetzt mal ganz negativ,
Verwalter, aber keine Gestalter.
Da wartet einer auf den anderen und insofern ist diese Chance an uns vorbeigegangen.
Die Amis haben die Shuttles ins Museum gefahren, dann haben die Russen,
ich weiß nicht genau, sechs, sieben Jahre lang ein Monopol gehabt.
Wer zur ISS wollte, der musste mit einer russischen Soyuz dorthin fliegen und
auch mit einer zurückkommen.
Und das ist so ein bisschen das, was mich eben so ein bisschen skeptisch stimmt,
ob wir die Vision haben, dass wir unbedingt da mitspielen wollen.
In Deutschland, wenn man Visionen hat, wird man ja zum Arzt geschickt,
das ist so ein bisschen das Problem dabei.
Stammt von Helmut Schmidt, naja gut.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, es war keine gute Empfehlung, so glaube ich.
Man sollte die Leute vielleicht dann auch eher mal in Charge setzen.
Aber ich meine, das ATV ist ja jetzt in Form von der Orion, wird es ja in gewisser
Hinsicht in diese Rolle gebracht werden.
Hat sich gelohnt.
ATV war natürlich ja auch bei Raumzeit schon ein Thema.
Also Artemis, jetzt die große neue Mondmission, die jetzt in den nächsten Jahren
dann auch wirklich mal mal Personen wieder auf den Mond bringen soll.
Das findet sozusagen ihren Zuspruch. Das lese ich jetzt mal so ein bisschen heraus.
Unbedingt, unbedingt.
Als erster Schritt hin zu einer Mondstation und was dann eben vielleicht die
Basis sein kann für so eine Mars-Mission.
Aber das wird dann wahrscheinlich noch ein bisschen dauern, bis wir auf dem Mars landen.
Ja klar, ich meine, das sollte man auch systematisch betreiben.
Und das ist eben auch so ein bisschen das Handicap.
Unsere, in diesem wundervollen demokratischen System, in dem wir leben dürfen,
da ist eben ein Politiker erst in der Lage, was zu gestalten,
nachdem er gewählt worden ist. Vorher kann er nichts machen.
Und die Wahlzeit, das sind vier Jahre heutzutage, dann geht es wieder von vorne
los, dann werden andere gewählt.
Die sagen dann, was mein Vorgänger gemacht hat, ich will mich mit etwas Eigenem
profilieren. Das ist so ein bisschen das Dilemma.
Also ein solches Projekt, das braucht einen langen Atem.
Und ich kann nur sagen, wir sollten uns vielleicht an der Stelle von den Franzosen
mal eine Scheibe abschneiden.
In Frankreich war das große Thema autonomer Zugang zum Weltraum.
Und hätten wir die Franzosen nicht gehabt, hätten wir die Ariane nicht so schnell
gekriegt. Das war französisches Staatsziel.
Egal ob Mitterrand, Giscard, wer immer Präsident in Frankreich war,
Hollande, wie die alle der Reihe nach hießen, da gab es überhaupt kein Vertun,
auch wenn die Partei gewechselt hat.
An diesem Ziel haben die Franzosen festgehalten.
Und das brauchen wir für eine solche Vision auch.
Wenn das in die Landtagswahlkämpfe käme oder sowas, dann wird da nichts draus.
Tja, gut, mehr bald.
Jetzt haben wir aber das All schon wieder mal ganz gut durchkreuzt.
Ich bedanke mich sehr für die Ausführungen.
Ist noch was, was wir uns noch so mit auf den Weg geben möchten?
Sie bringen mich hier in Schwierigkeiten. Also ich will die Gelegenheit benutzen,
um mich bei Ihnen zu bedanken.
Ich bin dreimal im Weltraum gewesen und das war für mich persönlich natürlich
eine aufregende Phase meines Lebens.
Aber ich denke mal, mit dem SpaceLab-Projekt, mit dem ich sozusagen viel Lebenszeit
zugebracht habe, hat Europa auch hinzugewonnen.
Ohne das Space Lab wären wir in meinen Augen nicht Partner an der ISS mit dem Columbus-Modul.
Und die ISS hat eben den Nachteil nicht, dass nach zehn Tagen das Ding am Boden
sein muss, sondern da kann man sehr viel länger und damit systematischer Wissenschaft betreiben.
Und Sie waren als Steuerzahler daran beteiligt und dafür möchte ich mich bedanken.
Super.
Gut, dann bleibt mir eigentlich auch nicht mehr sehr viel mehr,
als Ihnen zu danken, Herr Merwold und ich bedanke mich natürlich auch bei allen,
die hier gekommen sind zu Raumzeit.
Das war es dann für diese Ausgabe. Super, dass ihr alle dabei wart und wie immer
hier geht es auch bald wieder mit irgendeinem anderen thema wieder weiter und.
Ich sage tschüss und bis bald.